This episode of DNews is brought to you by
“How We Got To Now” with Steven Johnson
- premieres Wednesday October 15 at 9/8c on
PBS.
Three scientists who invented the LED were
awarded the Nobel Prize in physics this year.
But what have LED lights really done for us?
And more importantly, what can do they for
the rest of the world?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and in this
modern world, it can be easy to take for granted
just how much work and research went into
developing the things we use every day.
Take LEDs, for example.
The three scientists who pioneered the LED
- or light emitting diode - back in the early
90s, were just awarded the 2014 Nobel prize
in physics, which is exclusively awarded to
inventions that offer the greatest benefit
to mankind.
Of course, those of us living in first-world
countries may not view LEDs as anything more
than a way to save money on lightbulbs - but
as the official press release says, “LEDs
have the potential to increase the quality
of life for over 1.5 billion people around
the world who lack access to electricity grids.”
In the same way that Thomas Edison’s filament
bulb replaced gas lighting in the 19th century,
LEDs are poised to be the next big generation
of lighting technology.
They’re efficient, long-lasting, and by
the year 2050 - they’re expected to completely
replace fluorescent and incandescent bulbs.
Interestingly, when they first came about
in the 1980s, LEDs weren’t really all that
useful because at the time, they could only
emit green and red light.
It wasn’t until the 90s, when Shuji Nakamura
developed the first high-brightness blue LED,
that people realized the three of those colors
could be combined to produce white light - making
them acceptable for everyday use.
Since then, the technology has advanced at
a remarkable rate.
They’re roughly 15 times more efficient
than incandescent bulbs, meaning you wouldn’t
even need a power grid to use them.
Solar panels and small batteries would be
more than enough to power the homes of the
staggering 1.2 billion people in the world
who lack access to electricity.
Most of those households are still burning
wood or gas for light - which isn’t just
inefficient, it also creates indoor air pollution
that according to the WHO, kills more people
every year than AIDS, malaria, and tuberculosis
combined.
Currently, the biggest hurdle is cost.
If you consider their longevity, and the savings
in energy costs, then yes - LEDs are cheaper
than other types of lightbulbs.
It’s the upfront costs that are higher.
If you were to buy a 60W incandescent bulb
right now, it would cost you about a dollar.
A single LED bulb, however, with equivalent
brightness would be about $10.
So it is a big financial commitment, but it
also pays off in the long run.
Plus, LED bulbs - just like any technology
- get dramatically cheaper every year.
Eventually, the hope is that every household
in the world will have access to something
we here in developed nations, have had for
centuries now - the miracle of modern light.
Kinda puts things into perspective, doesn’t
it?
What do you guys think?
Were these guys deserving of the Nobel Prize?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
below - and as always, thank you guys for
watching!